I don't even think the most progressive
of the most progressive watches this and
goes that is passable as a woman and
she's gorgeous
let me ask you this before I get into
this
spoiler alert pansexual blind date Tran
pansexual blind date because it's
trending or Twitter for Valentine's Day
people say there is no normal you just
you just do you let me ask you this I
want to see your comments do you believe
there isn't normal because I know I know
we've we sort of try to break down
normal barriers or social norms for a
while because kids were being bullied I
was like listen you have to be a jockey
I understand that but is there
fundamentally unnormal at the end of the
day I I think there isn't normal and and
I like it
this same theme by the way is what
carries people I mean to the progressive
LUN just keeps getting pushed and pushed
and pushed to the point this was a story
all year that you're transphobic if you
don't date trans people right that's
something even Blair White was talking
about we've seen this all year long
which leads us to today's top trend onto
it for what half the day let's see let's
just go this is this is the trans
pansexual nightmare to fullhart brave
and courageous story go life is a
journey
some follow their own path regardless of
the consequences
meet David I definitely have more
challenges than publisher of rich
Preston people on the streets staring
and closed on them Davis and Trey baby
what would you change about your life if
she could I'd opt in one thing I changed
society I know a lot of the problem
doesn't start with you as an individual
I think everyone has the right to be who
they are what I would change the way
people business it's never me I change
society it's like asking it's like
asking a schizophrenic well what would
you change would you change the demons
clawing at your testicle everyone has a
right of a body arm
what about yeah oh let's go what okay
what about pedophiles yeah what about I
don't know people who like to harm them
what do people like to harm themselves I
know because we have we have suicide
laws we have self-harm laws we put
people into rehab rehabilitation clinics
we have zones date four year old dolls
so we have don't take for adults laws
and they'll say how dare you compare me
to data files well guess what only five
years ago when gay marriage was passing
they said how dare you compare me to
[ __ ] it's true the line just keeps
getting moved each time and we're like
told you everyone has a line that's it I
mean what you know they want to say
there's no there's no normal and they
want to guilt people if you don't want
it at what point is it okay where you
just walk right in you see David with a
penis and I'm a bigot okay and that's
the big point is people just own it
we're sick a racist you're racist or
you're transphobic no no no I'm not
transphobic can you show up for a blind
date and like I guess I'm a little
transfer o UT out no that's not
transphobic it's like he's got a penis
didn't even change the name David no I
just like what is that you're filling
out the application there it's like what
do you really yeah okay I like long
walks on the beach and I'm Dave and I
have a big fat what's funny is white
left convert everything all the other
alterations this this young strapping
young fellows made is the most
reasonable thing to change right that's
the most reasonable like that'd be the
starting point yeah it's like the the
first page in a Legos instructions yeah
go don't like you don't change masculine
Ellie or Jessie Tony visit journey I
think let's go there's another clip this
was the top trend on Twitter and that's
the reason we have to acknowledge is
because if you look at the Twitter
trends and I just can't this is amazing
I think most people are faking it I'm
sorry I think they're lying I don't even
think the most progressive of the most
progressive watches this and goes that
is passable as a woman
and she's gorgeous I don't think anyone
does it I think it's a lie I don't buy
I'm sorry I'm not ascribing one of maybe
some people do gun to my head I think
most people are bull crap and yet let's
say we have another clip right okay two
years ago
Wexler's my family are based in their
accent but I go to expert No
would you go back see myself as a female
kind of inside my head transition I
never really knew that that was a viable
option it's not when did you only two
years ago when I first met yeah are you
carrying you're giving slavery David no
I mean that's all kind of down the road
right now boots really aren't things to
deal with kind of change the pronouns
and then the surgery they
Oh doing my name's James they'll
probably like change the pronoun why are
you gonna change it to Layla time I see
myself quite similar to the way I am
today boss and physically as a woman a
woman physical and maybe not having to
explain so much because people have to
feel a bit more used to gender
nonconformity I suppose that's why the
blind date thing was kind of a bit
nerve-racking for me because you don't
know what way would be responded exactly
I'm a little bit out of my comfort zone
as well yes my comfort zone right now
would be a 12 gauge ahead it is unreal I
don't know what changed the pronouns
then I'll change my name you can't
change prone pronouns is what someone
else a little bit uh I got you owe money
he's two years into it and hasn't gotten
any further than linear transition I
began my transition hasn't changed your
name hasn't changed the anatomy at all
so what that means means you started
saying that you were a girl this is a
let's meet let's be honest what what we
see here okay there is a man named Dave
Dave has a penis dave has no breasts
Dave put on a wig and wears a dress
maybe he's been taking some estrogen
pills recently or having it it directly
injected into his left cheek but it is
Dave with a penis no breasts showing up
as a trans pansexual blind date let me
tell you something Dave you're not the
victim in all of this I want to see that
man somewhere at the local pub and buy
him a drink because the way he reacted
to you was absolutely saintly you're
gonna tell us that we're transphobic
because if we show up to this we want to
say you know what you're a crazy person
I'm gonna go take my chances at the bar
with the fat chicks who have low
self-esteem so I've got a better shot by
the way you got a
hey did you like this video it what you
didn't oh you're a cat person well that
makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below too as to why you don't
like it